oh
le premier a été attribué au collège les
noms se voit
j'attends
j'attends le moment aucun club huit mois
j'ai encore des mots que j'ai hâte il
est pas beau il ne reste pas indifférent
elles font le
trajet
laisse moi te dire on est soulagé
non
faux elles ne marchent marchent son but
crève dans la rue et bien personne ne
l'a vu de différence et l'indifférence
est remué copé même l'enfance elle ne
marche le match sombrait dans la rue et
bien personne ne l'a vu une différence
et indifférence
j'étais la première à danser je vais
chanter je pense et je sortais homé mais
je m'amuse et je buvais je fumais tout
le monde se marie on a trouvé
intéressante mais si les déferlantes et
lors de ces substances
j'ai cru pouvoir me contrôler j'ai cru
pouvoir l'arrêter si vous ne jouez avec
le feu et je le suis être maître du jeu
mais un jour je mets s'effondrer et
personne n'a relevé on avait peur moi on
dit nexus est tombé bluesy remparts
maintenant je suis seul sans personne à
qui parler seul sans personne à qui
confier celle avec ma dépendance
dans l'indifférence
on dit qu'elle est trop moche avec un
coeur
mais on
mais jusqu'à s'offrir au rexy encontre
séné n'a pas la cote de sa souffrance
cette société n'a pas donné par bateau
menace
dans enfin on
m
mais perso
mais seuls
avec la souffrance
on la différence
on ne sait pas
vous rejoignez demandé mais j'ai quand
même envie on a fait travail
comme wayne l'école rien de tel n'a été
pas les arrêter en foot ça on va
remettre a quand même qui pour moi est
la veste il est assez facile
tandis mollet sont bio bon oui cette
année même où tu sais quand les croquis
on a beau être
une union foot ou du type
je me sentais pas bien de cette société
wallon était donc
religion pour mon action
gaza 6 jan
en quoi sa venue si différents
jeux
mais je suis là ce n'est plus de saison
mais j'ai bon
et le regard
chantepie de m pourtant j'avais la même
couleur méchant pas nouvelle
ces serres
vous prenez un verre
tu apprends solitude
quand je suis seul
face à mes questions et juge seul
de nouvelles recherches
semblent traîner dans la rue eh bien
personne ne l'a vu la différence la
différence
non mais des fois t'es sûr vous me
donner un peu de punch et serait ce trop
demander et pendant qu'ils ratifient
casse-pieds natif à une erreur tu ne vas
pas te manger regard noir regarde moi je
si dieu non mais c'est en partie sur mes
théâtre abc serait ce trop demander et
pourtant demain tacite sarah âgée il
sera le jour où ton situé steira
qu'injecter prendra le bras côté d un
rossi
c'est différent ces personnes n'ont donc
pas besoin c'était tout à fait le cas de
ceux qui broient du noir c'est noir hier
il ajouté
la déception ce thème toujours
mais moi ça me met en colère
celle ci a marqué qu'un seul comté mais
j'espère être
tu fus malheureuse fait comme ce qui
fait d'eux des bassins et moi allait
bien mais fort la vie même
et
yaka
slam ça fait raconter ça peut être une
autre aventure
c'était tout est lisse et c'est nous
même qu'aux filles
minces et les
passionnés
parce qu'on est d'une heure parce qu'on
n'est
pas ce qu'on aime
toutefois ce fait le plein de haine
envers le précède et coloré pourquoi
montrer du doigt la femme ou l'homme et
manger il faut arrêter ces injures plus
de 100 sur le fn pendant la q1 faisons
de la france avait libéré stop à la
demande à cause des différences
critiques à l'étranger parce qu'ils
et se méfier de lui comme d'un ennemi
juré mais comment tu veux avancer avec
le selle français
mais c'est là le point commun qui
revient demain
toile alors que toi m'a dit papa tu as
vite on compare toujours service de la
tempête en pleurs minier défi c'était
toute sa famille et te laissons pas
marché mais tu est rester légère en
cassant des pierres tu es devenu
président sans verser de sang ferme les
yeux imagine toi à la place de monter la
ferme les yeux imagine ce que tu c'est
vrai qu'ils n'étaient pas là si tu ce
qu'il a enduré études déjà menées à 5
face à cette fois chacun sait que te
plaindre le gars que tu as et la passe
et les doubles d'établir mon journée la
merde en prison et toi tu jettes à
moitié les têtes par le jour toi je t'ai
la revue nature
nous séparer de liberté et s'achève
onéreux pour appeler c'est toute chose
que vous avez et pouvoir librement vous
exprimer trois ans prison soit votre la
ségrégation tout ça pour prouver sa
véritable identité bon bah tu encourages
la vie ou de disons merci
mon dieu
un bon débat
mais je pense que c'est bien ça permet
aux jeunes de
s'exprimer
et puis des découvre plein de jeunes
talents
on le sent
châteauroux lui faut
démissionner trois
ans
deux valises
une âme
leur vie en ami
lui du bon sauf
conçus
dont gérard lanvin tout possible et
toulouse tous continuez toujours se
limiter chaque jour aussi
sar o'shea sarrance très grande
chaque jour vous amuse ça bouge ça vous
dépeignez
par un sujet des amendes distribuées
dans les objets
il succombe à la tentation de la société
de consommation qui les consume un petit
peu en poussant un concept est toujours
lui
censure à la même utilisation à la
sous-alimentation et à la déshydratation
qui les consume à petit me on les a
souvent et les a vraiment morose
et toi et toi et toi
qu'attendent-ils auras-tu attaché à dieu
a rapporté que en tout cas on était au
pas combien de temps continuer là-dessus
a jeté plus que de raison a ajouté celle
qui n'a pas mangé à gaspiller sans arrêt
à la même société de consommation
en plus des ponts soir au lieu de
dépenser et vient en aide à ceux qui en
ont besoin faut qu'il n'est pas du
triste fin à cause de la fin
des nouvelles choses
des émotions à la main aux français pas
connaître mais aussi hélas et le chant
des vous laisse l'accès baisse et le kwh
m2 à rebondissements
l'histoire